John Salisbury joining us the former NFL
quarterback hosted the chanson show you
were you were a big man on campus at USC
right yeah I didn't have any acne but I
did have long hair and I could pull you
know you were even if you weren't a
starter at USC you were doing well whoa
whoa whoa no no that was reserved for my
NFL backup role I was a starter at us no
no but even if even if your backup
wasn't you know he's just your fourth
quarterback at USC you walk into the
walked on sorority fraternity row I
played quarterback USC it doesn't matter
if your 1st or 8th you it's it's a very
popular position on campus wait wait
wait did you ever wear your jersey on
campus I never wore by Jersey ok yeah I
was the guy who tucked his Jersey into
his high jeans and pulled them up to his
chest and where the number comes down so
low yeah you only see half the number
because the guy tucked his jersey in so
much and here you guys are talking about
Chester lemon yeah and Roger Moretti
yeah the cagey left-hander drafty well
you know I think I bring this up about
you know on campus Jon Gruden went to
Dayton and John would wear his football
leather jacket around on campus with a
football in his hands all the time he
didn't play but he was he gave you the
impression that you know I'm a football
player and I got my letter jacket on
yeah is it like the guy who gets like a
championship ring but never played but
he believes that the Barney's tapping it
on hoping there's somebody next to him
sees that he has a ring on type of thing
I would do that she is he moved by
Gruden but it's worked yeah look at him
now man I need I need to try that didn't
work for me dan I need to try the Jersey
and Letterman's jacket thing all right I
love your analysis because you're you're
very astute at looking at quarterbacks
and I love your opinions and I and it
comes down to this
with the quarterbacking position now in
how we draft or woody but do we look for
in a quarterback as opposed to you know
ten years ago Kyler Murray is probably
made into a wide receiver or a kick
returner but you know he's sort of we're
not sure what to do you know we can't
place
in a position where everybody goes okay
that's exactly what he is like what do
you what do you know about Cuyler Murray
that says he will be successful in the
NFL well then I've changed my narrative
on him probably more than I've changed
on any quarterback in such a short
period time maybe the last three or four
months I fell into that trap and I don't
want to first of all the size thing
we've got to get rid of that as a matter
of fact there's more quarterbacks under
six foot Fran Tarkenton rusts you know
Russell Wilson Drew Brees this kid who
have been more successful than guys like
over six feet six so this heightened
size and we got to get rid of that we've
got to start treating quarterbacks and
athletes a little different in my mind I
went back and watched three or four is
for his games after the season was over
just to watch and when he was doing some
good things and some bad things and I
know Dan you've been talking a lot about
him yeah if I was Arizona Cardinals I
would consider I would answer every
phone call for Josh Rosen I think as we
speak today he's a better play maker
than Rosen is now that doesn't mean
Rosen can't be a good player I think he
can with the right situation but with
cliff and with Kyler if he gets out of
the top ten it's it's criminal
did somebody didn't take him the top ten
he's active accurate he has plenty of
arm I've never seen a guy stop and start
quick or maybe since Barry Sanders and
especially at the quarterback position
he gets skinny and small too everybody
talks about can you handle the
punishment six five guys there's a lot
of room to hit like me you could there's
a lot of room to hit couldn't move yeah
this guy is like a running back who gets
skinny in the hole he doesn't give you a
lot to hit I've changed Danny I went
back and watch him I was under now
fourth or fifth round guys a baseball
guy great athlete and I love multi-sport
athletes I'm telling you right now this
guy I believe he's going to be a star in
the league I believe he's one of those
guys that once he gets the job you don't
get it back he wins and Dan every time
you watch him on film I can go around
the league right now the NFL or college
and find you quarterbacks that are never
the best player on the field
ever I can go watch this dude and he's
always always the best player on the
field and he wins and there's something
to be said for that I will be shocked if
he's fallen out of the top ten and I
will not be shocked if he's picked first
or in the top five I wouldn't hurt top
six I've made the point
if your Arizona and you're gonna already
change the paradigm there and you bring
in Kliff Kingsbury alright you're
looking for something unique you're
making a big change with a guy who had a
losing record in college great offense
in mind and is on record as saying I
take Kyler Murray if I had that
opportunity to take him number one
overall if I could send Josh Rosen to
the Patriots let's say yep and I could
bring in Kyler Murray let's say I get
the Patriots late first-round pick for
Josh Rosen it seems like a win-win for
both sides here
I think a matter of fact that phone call
should last 30 seconds Dan
Rosen goes and gets to learn behind
Brady and gets to be with Josh McDaniels
it was perfect for him
what does they do remember the the
narrative on Rosen when he came out as
the most NFL ready and quite frankly of
all the guys draft in the first round he
progressed the least so that would be
great for him and then your cliff this
is what you do the kid knows the verbage
he's an explosive talent if you're gonna
go go all in yeah why go 72% in and then
two years later say oh man maybe we
should have what like any other position
and if we fail on a defensive end and
end of the quarterback position sets
franchises back but this kid with the
only thing that's not to like if he was
six foot one he'd be the first pick of
the draft and they'd do everything they
could to maneuver two people to trade up
to get him simple to two or three
princes and the guy's a play it's just
stupid it's a dumb narrative but you
think about how will three late three
years down the road if you're gonna go
go all in because what happens the
defensive end we drafted me doesn't work
we get another one quarterback doesn't
work okay two three years down the road
we'll go get another one
it's a rough position to analyze it's a
tough position to find out if the guys
got it kind of Murray does now whether
he's going to be a superstar not it
remains to be seen but I know he plays
well under pressure he elevates his play
against good players and I've never seen
him other than you know maybe one or two
times on the field where like he looks
confused other than that he looks in
complete control football IQ accurate if
I'm Arizona
I'm not even hesitating on this if I can
get a first-round pick for Rosen
somewhere I'm shipping him and I'm
drafting Kyler Murray and let's do what
cliff does let's put that kid in that
offense and let's cut it loose I think
Kyler Murray
is a franchise changer with his ability
okay this is my idea I know the Giants
have they appear to be locked in on
Dwayne Haskins out of Ohio State if I'm
the Giants I go after Cuyler Murray
because I gots a Quon Berkeley and Odell
Beckham jr. now I want to see how you
adjust to our speed as we you know you
have those sweeps you don't like I I'm
gonna come at you and you're gonna go oh
my god I'm in a track meet here and I I
would just change I would turn the NFL
on its ear and Joe with those three if I
could put Cuyler Murray in there on that
turf and I know that the Giants love
their six-four six-five quarterback if
you look back Eli and Phil Simms and
Jeff Hostetler man you put him on turf
with se Kwan and Odell Beckham and man I
just think that would be some fun well
we got I mean yeah they like their big
quarterbacks but this is a chance to
change things completely I can remember
when Barry Sanders we played against him
twice a year you can't simulate speed
man you just can't we put a Paul palm
when we took anybody a running back wide
receiver slot guy tried to make him the
quarterback that week during the you
know practice week and then we go play
Barry Sanders and our defensive backs
were tackling error it could they hug
dare because Barry was so good Kyler
Murray the elusiveness you get those
three cats together now I loved Wayne
Haskins he plays great under pressure
late in games great football IQ if the
Giants don't get him somebody else
should get him quick because I like that
kid a lot I like how he processes
information but Murray hmm with that
speed Dan how do you how do you defend
it all you talk about the big three even
though they may be small in stature I
don't know how you would defend it so if
you're gonna set the NFL on its ear
Kyler's Murray's the guy to do it and I
know people I can't stand it he's too
small well you know what I hear that all
the time yet the kid keeps playing on at
Oklahoma keeps succeeding everywhere he
goes they find a way to win I love the
fact that he's competitive now I needs
to be a better interview did you did you
see the interview on my show did I ever
see I was cringing at the same time wait
you're going into the interview you know
Dan's gonna ask probing questions just
be prepared to give me an answer I loved
when you had to call on the pops in the
stands he wasn't giving you an answer he
shook me off yeah at one point I go and
you know this is on this microphone is
on yes well you handled it great but
he's gonna have to get better at that
because he's going to be the face of a
franchise to understand that those
things happen and going to New York
they're gonna happen rampantly if he
goes there so I'm with you Dan you can't
simulate speed you just can't the kids a
look you see I used to look at him dan
as a baseball player athlete who was
just the dynamic football quarterback
because he was a good athlete I've
changed I think he's a quarterback who
just happens to be a great baseball
player and an athlete like I said you
had three inches to his height we
wouldn't even be having this discussion
and we still shouldn't be having this
discussion the guy's a winner and he's a
dynamic game changer and probably will
turn a franchise or the teams that play
it on it's here that's how that's how
dynamic he is good to visit with you and
with you we'll catch up with you soon
thank you buddy Shawn Salisbury for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show at
[Music]